one of the most important lessons we've
learned from overseas
is the need to go hard and go early
and stamp out flare-ups to avoid the
risk of wider outbreak
as disruptive it is as it is a strong
and rapid health response remains the
best
long-term economic response
in line with our precautionary approach
we will be asking aucklanders to take
swift
action with us as of 12
noon tomorrow wednesday august 12th
we will be moving auckland to level 3
restrictions
for a period of three days
until midnight on friday
these three days will give us time to
assess the situation
gather information make sure we have
widespread contact tracing so we can
find out more about how this case arose
and make decisions on how to respond to
it
once we have further information
let me set out what that means for
aucklanders and the rest of new zealand
we are asking people in auckland to stay
home to stop the
spread this means doing the simple
things that you will already be familiar
with to prevent picking up the virus or
passing it on to others
first act as if you have covered and as
if the people around you have covered
at level three you're asked to stay at
home in your bubble
other than for essential movements such
as going to the supermarket
or local recreation if you are in
auckland you must work from home unless
you are
an essential service worker all schools
and child care facilities in auckland
are closed as of tomorrow morning except
for the children of essential service
workers
and those who who are involved will
remember that at level 3 we allow
you to access schools and early
childhood for
a level 3 for essential service workers
only
all public facilities bars restaurants
and businesses must close
by midday tomorrow gatherings of more
than 10 people in auckland again
will be restricted and are restricted
again for funerals
tangihanga and wedding services only
and the rest of the country gatherings
of course though
i'll outline in further detail
momentarily
traveling into auckland is prohibited
unless you normally reside there
and are traveling home if you are
currently
in auckland but do not normally reside
there
you also can leave to go home but we are
asking you to be very conscious of your
health
and if you begin to display any symptoms
please get tested
we are defining the area covered as
auckland and covered by level three
restrictions
is the geographic boundary of the
auckland super city
which extends from wellsford in the
north to pukakoi in the south
police will be issuing further guidance
on parameters including roadblock use
first thing in the morning as you will
recall
all key services supermarkets pharmacies
medical centers they do remain open
so food and supplies will continue to be
readily available
food delivery is also available as you
recall
at level three please do not rush to the
supermarket tonight you'll recall
as when we were in level three on our
last occasion supermarkets will be open
there will be ample stock on the shelves
there is no reason
to go out and make any purchases this
evening
if you operated as an essential service
under level 4 and level 3 last time
then those are the settings we revert to
at level three again if in doubt
stay at home tomorrow until you have
clarity from your employer